[Música]
no nordeste do brasil no ano de 1985 mas
precisamente na cidade de são tomé no
interior do rio grande do norte
era preciso muita sabedoria criatividade
inteligência pra sobreviver na época de
seca
eu penso que não é necessariamente a
inteligência tem a ver com o
conhecimento mas o conhecimento é claro
que exercitam cérebro e faz a gente
ficar mais inteligente é mas eu acho que
todos os povos pode ser inteligente
porque o que mais forte o nosso cérebro
a a esse exercício é a sobrevivente
e foi aí que meus pais cresceram se
conheceram e começaram o seu
relacionamento é e sobreviveram por
muito tempo e se tornar inteligente
logo que descobriram que eu o terceiro
filho dele estava a caminho
eles decidiram migrar juntos para o sul
foram meio na loucura tipo não sabia o
local certo que o paraná foram contra a
vontade da família e tudo mais
[Música]
acabaram parando na cidade de santa
vitória no interior de minas gerais pra
trabalhar na colheita de algodão e logo
nascia ali é eu lembro que ela sempre
conta com orgulho assim certo orgulho de
que na época é e com 15 quilos de 57
cêntimos e um bebê gigante
todo mundo comentou na cidade como a
cidade era muito pequeno e ela fala com
orgulho assim que chegou a receber
a visita do prefeito da cidade para
conhecer o tal bebês gigantes da da
cidade
enfim mas depois meu pai conseguiu
emprego muito rápido é como pedreiro na
cidade de ribeirão preto que estava em
desenvolvimento na época ea gente se
mudou para lá então eu acabei conhecendo
ali é essa é uma das poucas fotos do meu
pai eu não gostava muito da fota e da
minha mãe é no meu aniversário de 6 anos
é logo depois disso meu pai descobriu
que estava com câncer e acabou falecendo
um ano depois preto era uma cidade muito
violenta e eu foi considerado a cidade
mais violenta do do pai quando eu tava
com um na minha fase pré adolescente de
10 para 12 anos
é eu ainda morava na periferia e preciso
um bairro muito violenta e na na época
do do auge da guerra do tráfico ali a
gente conviveu com muita violência nessa
época
minha mãe já estava com uma tem mais uma
filha um quarto filho e precisar de
muita inteligência força e criatividade
pra criar agentes em que a gente se
envolvesse com toda referência ruim que
a gente não tinha de perto no bairro
eu lembro que tinha dias que no auge da
guerra é todos os dias morre alguém
perto do meu bairro
por causa dessa violência toda aqui que
estava em alta e eu meus irmãos meus
amigos sempre que ficava sabendo de
algum crime alguma coisa um assassinato
a gente até o local para tentar ver o
que aconteceu e depois ficar comentando
tipo que morreu que matou quem quem era
o maior matador da cidade e tudo mais é
então minha mãe nessa época ela teve que
ser muito criativa de novo inteligente
foi forte pra conseguir criar todos nós
todos os filhos com deixar que a gente
se envolvesse com essa referência ruim
que a gente vivia no bairro
então eu aproveito aqui minha mãe está
aqui comigo proveito pra falar pra ela é
parabéns você venceu nessa linda
maravilhosa e guerreira e vencedor
ela tinha muitas formas de convencer a
gente a fazer a coisa certa ela mas acho
que a principal característica dela era
pedir e não mandar ela pedir a gente não
merecia
ela é divertida e raramente precisava de
inverter
logo depois dessa fase de de violência
eu entrei em outra fase da minha vida eu
acho que a gente o ser humano pra mim é
uma espécie é que eu falo que detesta
mas ao mesmo tempo acho que é mais
incrível do planeta não tem como negar
isso
eu acho que ele é capaz de criar
técnicas e habilidades para fazer a
gente se inverter
e para marcar a existência dele pra
outras gerações
acho que a única peça que faz isso
foi assim que no bairro onde eu cresci é
e não é mais incrível disso aqui
se um grupo ser humano foram deixados em
qualquer lugar sem sem essa cultura é
uma forma de tentar definir a cultura
esse grupo ser humano foi deixado sem
cultura ele é capaz de criar o seu
próprio a sua própria cultura
e foi assim que nesse bairro também eu
conheci muita coisa boa muitas culturas
diferentes que são de preferir mas a que
mais me chamou a atenção na época foi a
cultura da pichação que eu falo arte da
pichação
parece estranho arte da pichação mas não
é só pra mim que a captação é
considerado um art
ela já ganhou espaço em várias galerias
e várias marcas grandes estão usando ela
como um fins comerciais e tudo mais
parece estranho mas eu entendo que a
pichação deixa a cidade feia taticamente
mas a gente podia discutir aqui um
tempão falando sobre o que é feio que é
bonito itália várias opiniões diferentes
mas no geral eu entendo que a maioria da
população associação feia e não vou
discutir mais aqui mas que atire a
primeira pedra quem nunca fez uma
pichação linha nem que seja aquela na
carteira da escola ou qualquer coisa
assim
então é assim ninguém atirou uma pedra
ou é porque ninguém tem pedra eu porque
somos todos os pichadores e antes mesmo
tempo é recentemente ao fim da viagem
para a europa eu acabei de chegar de lá
na verdade passei dois meses lá eu fui
convidado para participar de alguns
festivais de arte e fazer alguns
trabalhos mas eu vou nessas viagens não
pra lucrar um pouco de propósito porque
o que mais lucro é a oportunidade de
conhecer a cultura diferente é pintar
com artistas que eu admiro têm contato
direto com ele
isso pra mim era uma explosão de
criatividade no final e aí foi nela que
eu nessa viagem que eu escolhi
projetei essa tal que eu estava no norte
da frança lille na cidade ele estava sem
nada na agenda
e aí eu resolvi começar mas escrever que
eu estava meio travado eu tinha o título
eu queria liberdade criativa mas estava
meio travado e foi para a sacada do
prédio estava aí comecei a ficar
é minha esposa e minha filha de 1 ano
estava comigo e minha filha estava
tirando a concentração na sala porque
ela estava brincando e estava
atrapalhando mas eu não estava
conseguindo me concentrando
e aí de repente ela bateu no vidro e de
ficou batendo no vidro sim e aí eu
peguei ela é e brincar e ela pegou a
minha mão segura bem certinho lápis e
começou a ficar depois ela pegou a
caneta arriscou mais e aí saiu fora e
deixou essa obra de arte
para muitos parece só um desenho de
criança mas pra mim foi inspirador
center participar as letras e pais que
fazem pontos diferentes
é uma arte só dela livre sem nenhuma
restrição ela fez do jeito dela viu a
fazer que fazer mais feliz do jeito dela
é muitos artistas muitos pensadores
pessoas importantes do mundo todo de
diversas áreas
já falaram sobre se referiram a criança
quando o assunto é criatividade separei
assim quando eu tinha 15 anos sabia
desenhar como rafael mas precisei da
vida inteira pra aprender a desenhar com
as crianças de casa dispensa
apresentações
a infância é o tempo de maior
criatividade na vida de um ser humano
jean piaget essa frase parece frágil de
criança é bem simples mas o jean piaget
foi um grande pensador do século passado
que escreveu muitos livros com esse tema
inspirado nos seus filhos também a
criatividade a inteligência se
divertindo e diversão
eu durante e depois dessa fase de crimes
eu conheci na rua que morava o skate e
aí através do skate eu conhecia o hip
hop e felizmente eu não achei nenhuma
foto dos meus amigos aqui que está
viajando e não tinha foto
sim irmãos mas a oposição uma foto
nenhum dano
mas eles foram muito importantes nessa
época é e aí o hip hop eu tenho que
explicar um pouco sobre ele porque muita
gente confunde o hip hop com o estilo
musical
mas não é só isso ele tem é é união de
quatro culturas diferentes que a gente
chama de elementos que junto com os
dizeres fazendo rap os b boys que dançam
e dança um break the boys mil e grafite
e os gracie eo grafite que conjunta como
arte visual
essa união dos quatro elementos começou
com festas no brooklin bairro de nova
york na década de 70 mas rapidamente se
espalhou pelo mundo todo muito rápido
como um movimento social que dava força
para o povo pobre e principalmente preto
que sofreu ainda mais que hoje com um
preconceito racial
eu comecei com letra de ser uma pintura
que eu fiz com meu amigo tom é ele fez a
personagem o fim das letras ea tradução
da palavra grafite vem do latim é
escrever então basicamente grafite e
grafite mesmo é você escrever seu nome
nas coisas depois eu passei a fazer
personagem desenho com o tema do desenho
era muito influenciada pelo hip hop foi
muito bom conseguir pintar muito nessa
época pode perder muito do evento
mas eu notei que ela tinha um pouco de
restrição é tanto hip hop quanto
enquanto um toda a sociedade da época
ela era muito machista e homofóbica e
isso criou barreiras na minha arte na
minha liberdade criativa e durante muito
tempo foi só
é expressada através do estilo hip hop
se não foi ruim era tipo era uma arte
mais agressivo então eu gosto dela até
hoje num igual e ainda hoje faço mas
acho que o fato de isso é uma regra
virou um problema então eu comecei a me
tornar verdadeiramente artista entende
isso é depois eu criei um personagem que
ela esteja inspirado na minha própria
personalidade
ele era um personagem que se esperava
que era inserido nas culturas urbanas
mas que é inspirado o apaixonado pela
natureza
isso me deu uma repercussão eu comecei a
ter o trabalho reconhecido dentro e fora
do brasil é depois eu criei o personagem
eu coloquei o nome de seu personagem de
caçador de flores foi a outra fase da
minha vida onde eu comecei a me inspirar
no na natureza
existiam na cidade e aí era como flores
que brotam no mês já dura do concreto
pássaros que fazem ninhos nos fios
elétricos rios que cortam a cidade e
deixa cheio de vida e deixa a cidade pra
mim - a professora e mais habitável
a partir daí eu realmente me senti o
artista e comecei a evoluir muito na
arte
mas ainda assim eu tinha um certo receio
quando eu ia criar eu pensava sempre que
é minha arte tinha que remeter ao que eu
era e eu tentava expressar um pouco de
masculinidade de agressividade tentava
passar uma uma imagem do que viver
entendeu e isso eu descobri depois que
era uma barreira na na minha
criatividade na minha liberdade criativa
e partir do momento que eu passei a me
sentir é mais livre e verdadeiramente
homem sem precisar provar que eu era uma
empresa ninguém
foi aí que eu realmente vi meu trabalho
é esse expandir e evoluir
eu acredito que aí sim eu virei um
artista
eu passei a me expressar da mesma forma
que minha filha fez no meu papel escrito
liberdade criativa da mesma forma como a
minha mãe meu pai decidiram com muita
atitude e fugir para o sul do país em
busca de uma vida melhor e o hip hop
acompanhou isso ele passou a à luta que
era pelo direito dos pretos e pobres
abriu espaço para várias outras lutas e
hoje o hip hop é muito mais completo e
abre espaço pra coisas como é
direitos iguais para os gêneros é
liberdade é pra expressão lgbt é não
está contra a homofobia e por aí vai
e aí eu passei a pintar do jeito que eu
queria por borboletas rosa é flores e aí
eu acho que a minha arte realmente virou
o que é hoje e hoje singh
eu me sinto livre pra criar me expressar
e é isso que eu busco daqui pra frente
da minha arte
ainda tenho acho que eu tenho uma
trajetória muito grande e eu procuro me
expressar dessa forma e acho que isso a
gente leva também para a vida
é a gente tem que se expressar e criar
de maneira livre para ser único e
original
obrigado
[Aplausos]